in today's society it is more and more
often required that we are awake at
night it may be because of shift work it
may be because we are studying very hard
for an exam to really understand what is
happening when you're pulling such an
all-nighter is important because Society
your boss wants you to be awake at night
your biological clock wants you to sleep
at that particular time almost all
organisms on earth use internal
biological clocks called circadian
clocks to help them adapt to the cycle
of night and day as humans we have a
circadian clock in our brain that among
other things helps us to stay alert and
awake during the day and to sleep at
night so what happens when we break this
cycle and don't go to sleep at all here
at the University of Surrey in the
Surrey Sleep Research Center we have
specialized facilities which allow us to
study the effects of pulling an
all-nighter under very controlled
conditions the participants are kept
awake for forty or forty two hours while
you are lying in a bed in a dimly lit
room these bedrooms are sound attenuated
obviously light controlled temperature
controlled we can study the cognition in
these individuals we can simply ask them
how sleepy they are we can draw blood
samples and then look at the rhythms in
hormones and of course we can record
their brainwaves to quantify sleep and
wakefulness we can actually see what the
biological clock is telling to the rest
of the body and to the rest of the brain
if you keep someone awake for 40 hours
straight and measure their alertness you
find something surprising
instead of alertness dropping and
getting worse the longer someone is kept
awake as it gets to morning on the
second day of sleep deprivation
alertness actually starts to increase
again this is because there are two
forces controlling when we should sleep
the first is sleep pressure which builds
up the longer we are awake but the
second is our circadian clock which
drives alertness during the day but
promotes sleep at night
it's a circadian clock gives us a fresh
burst of alertness on the second day as
it stops promoting sleep and starts
promoting wakefulness again so when you
are a shift worker but you don't go to
sleep at 10 o'clock in the morning off
the United shift but you stay awake as
the participants in our sleep
deprivation protocols do you will find
it slightly easier the second day so
despite you haven't been awake now for
27 or 35 hours can stay awake easier
because the clock during the biological
day will help you to stay awake what do
we learn from the studies well first of
all if we understand the interaction
between those CKD and rhythms and our
sleep/wake cycle then we can design for
example shift work schedules that will
lead to less disruption of brain
function understanding this interaction
may also help us to understand why in
certain neurodegenerative diseases
disruption of the sleep/wake cycle is is
so important and how maybe by rescuing
the sleep/wake cycle we can ameliorate
some of the effects of those
neurodegenerative diseases or even the
effects of aging itself
[Music]
you
[Music]